does the dubstep guns video I hope you
guys liked it welcome to the making of
in this making up we're gonna go over a
bunch of cool stuff like how you do the
laser Sam yo how'd you the split screens
Mike yo how'd you do the speed ramps
Nikko and check this out when you're
done with this one check out Mike's
channel because he's putting up another
making up that covers even more stuff
one day so Nikko sound what do you guys
get this location and one of our
neighbors was like hey guys my dad's
from the plant manager of this brick
factory got past 47 years the big
demolished next weekend do you guys want
to come there and immortalize the
factory in the video Andrew came over
today and his dad watched the video and
he smiled and said righteous before we
were doing the video I was thinking
alright how are you to do lasers for
this we're watching a lot of Gundam Wing
specifically in the cartoons the lasers
of these giant streaks of light and I
was thinking how can we create this as
best as possible so it's checking out
the trapcode form plugin normally it's
made promotion graphics but I realized
that it was easily manipulated to kind
of making these insane laser patterns
essentially and he became master laser
so the most important part of tailoring
the lasers for the video was animating
as many characteristics of the lasers as
I could most importantly I would change
the intensity shape and color alter the
rhythm of the song as well as layering
additional elements on top this was done
for each of our lasers and depending on
which part of the song they played and
we had changed them as necessary and
making sure that each character had a
distinct laser was crucial for the piece
and to place them in the shot
I would link all the elements together
align them in 3d space create a
displacement map from those same layers
and voila
only 30 shots to go the final laser
blast incorporates both laser effects
and some excellent speed ramping for the
speed ram shots
we'd carefully move along the path of
the camera then afterwards we'd
stabilize the footage and retime it
with the rough 3d track of the shot we
then start adding elements in such as
this awesome laser ball this particular
technique of stabilizing and ramping
allows us to get extremely dynamic
camera angles actually it's funny while
I was on vacation I had an anxiety dream
where I accidentally uploaded dubstep
guns to the main channel it was all
black it was just the subtitles for
everything that was being said in the
video 50,000 people just saw this black
clip this is an end passionate about
what he does and then dreams of YouTube
hope you like the video and learn
something if you want a little bit more
check out Mike's channel because he's
posting a behind the scenes video with a
bunch of other stuff we haven't even
covered yet stuff that's possibly more
interesting to you also check out our
Facebook page we're posting a lot of
behind the scenes photos that you
haven't seen yet nobody's seen them I
haven't even seen thanks Nico
good really yeah like I had a fantastic
experience and there's a great
it was a great opportunity in my life
you go